hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
one of the very important chapters in
essay one
of nietzsche's genealogy of morals
is chapter 13 where he's talking about
birds of prey
or how full right and little
lambs very stark
contrast here for the strong and the
weak
the good in the original valuation and
the bad
in the original evaluation or as we're
going to see
in the secondary or herd morality
evaluation the transvaluation of values
the good and the evil and
nietzsche's reflections here are really
important because
they don't just touch on something
genealogical
he's also making some points about you
could call
it the metaphysics of action and the
will
in general so the metaphysics of the
human person and he tells us that this
this there's a sort of way of looking at
things
that he thinks is metaphysically
mistaken he calls it the
common way it's also the way of the
person of resonte mont
and we can tie it in with the little
lambs and the birds of prey the little
lambs
don't like the birds of prey because the
birds of prey are mean to them
and they do things that they don't like
like prey upon them right
and he says that the lambs say that the
birds of prey and not only the birds of
prey
but more generally anybody else who acts
that way so even a little lamb when a
little lamb behaves that way
temporarily if they have a little bit of
power or something they are
evil they are booze they're bad in that
sense
bad in a you know different sense
than the weak or common
you know associated with schlecht that
the birds of prey
say about the the weak
being the opposite of that would then be
good so he says
the lamb that the lambs just like great
birds of prey doesn't seem
strange right um and if the lambs say
among themselves these birds of prayer
are evil and whoever is at least like a
bird of prey
but rather it's opposite a lamb would he
not be good nietzsche says there's no
reason to find fault with this
institution of an ideal
except perhaps that the birds of prey
might view it a little ironically and
say
we don't dislike them at all the good
little lambs we even love them nothing
is more tasty than a tender lamb
so the the birds of prey can still rise
above it but
part of the metaphysics of the human
person
that's being rolled out and deployed
is giving the little lambs a
cultural advantage and the key
assumption here
is that everybody is fundamentally
free to be either of these and because
of that
nietzsche uses this term in a verbal
sense
but here in kaufman's translation it's
that the
birds of prey are accountable for being
birds of praise says make the bird of
prey accountable
zurach then right reknon is this this
term that has to do with reckoning
is a kind of a cognate with it we think
about the value of things
duractin here has the the sense of
making these birds of prey who aren't
accountable
that's why they act the way that they
are making them accountable by
attributing to them
a kind of freedom a capacity to choose
otherwise
than they do nietzsche thinks that this
is fundamentally mistaken
and here's here's his explanation for it
so he says to demand of strength that it
should not express itself
externalize itself as strength
that it should not be a desire to
overcome a desire to throw down a desire
to become master
a thirst for enemies and resistances and
triumphs
is just as absurd as to demand of
weakness that it should express itself
as strength so notice the different
things that he's talking about
strength or force and uses both of these
terms
expresses itself as what it is so
strength
involves a desire to overcome a desire
to
master to to place oneself above
others and to control and then he says
a thirst for what enemies resistances
and triumphs a thirst for opposition
right needing enemies to be there so
that you can then clash with them
that's how you externalize strength
that's how you express it
and so strength that's that's part of
what's inherent to it
he says a quantum of force is equivalent
to a quantum
a number right a certain amount of drive
will effect more it's nothing
other than precisely this very driving
willing effecting and only owing to the
seduction of language and the
fundamental errors of reason that are
petrified in it
which conceives and misconceives all
effects is conditioned by something that
causes effects
can it appear otherwise so there's the
reality of things
and then there's the error or delusion
that is caused by language
and a certain way of reasoning about it
that we're you know
habitually uh falling into
so according to nietzsche there is no
being behind
the doing right he goes on and he says
there is no substratum there is nothing
like underlying things
there is no being no sign behind doing
effecting making making real vican
right becoming the aden the doer is
merely a
fiction added to the deed the deed is
everything now
you know maybe we're going a little bit
too far with this because we can say
does that mean there aren't any stable
human beings nietzsche is not asserting
that but he is saying
that this notion of there being like
this neutral
free will that gets to decide and then
either goes for the good
being nice to people goes for the bad
being mean to people
being weak acting like the weak acting
like the strong he says that
is not that's not real certainly not in
the the strong
and not in the weak either uh maybe it
isn't some weird
amalgam that we'll talk about later on
down the line
so this is his position right he says
scientists do better when they say force
moves force causes and like
it's all it's coolness it's freedom from
emotion none with
our entire science still lies under the
misleading influence of language
and we're you know we fall into these
mistakes of looking for the conscient
thing in itself
or the atom or stuff like that or the
radically
free will nietzsche is not saying by the
way that we don't have a will
will is absolutely central to his
understanding of the human person and
metaphysics and you know what's going on
with morality
it's just not the will that the the way
that people portray it to be
is right that's that's a a mistake
according to him
he talks about a doubling of the doing
so what is the mistaken point of view
he tells us going back to this
um here we go owing to the seduction of
language
and the fundamental errors of reason
which conceives and misconceives all
effects
as conditioned by something that causes
effects by a
subject right the subject in this case
would be
me the acting person who can be a bird
of prey or a
nice little lamb and he goes on and he
says
as the popular mind separates the
lightning from its flash
and takes the latter the flash for an
action for the operation of a subject
called lightning
so popular morality also separates
strength from the expression
of strength it says well you you could
just keep the strength inside
bottle it up don't express it in such a
way
as to be you know a bird of prey a mean
person
a forceful person a strong person
he says
as if there were a neutral substratum
behind the strong man which was free
to express strength or not to do so so
what what is nature actually saying here
he's saying the strong person inevitably
is going to
show themselves as strong by behaving
that way by
you know clashing by dominating by
desiring
all of those sorts of things they are
full of energy and how do you know that
because that energy is going to flow out
it's not like a
you know a reservoir where it can just
stay inside
uh and do nothing right and so
he goes on and he says that the the
people who are filled with resentment
right they exploit this this belief that
the strong person is free to be weak and
the bird of prey
to be a lamb this is what makes them
accountable to to them and so he goes
and he says when the oppressed downtrend
and outrage
exhort one another they say let us be
different from the evil
namely good he is good who does not
outrage who harms nobody
who does not attack who does not requite
who leaves revenge to
god he goes on and on and on right he
says
what this really amounts to is saying we
weak ones
are after all weak it would be good if
we did nothing for which we are not
strong enough
but what they do instead is they say
that there is
in all of us the same basic capacity
he says it clan it dresses itself up in
the ostentatious garb
of the virtue of quiet calm resignation
just as if the weakness of the weak that
is to say their essence what it is that
they are
how do they show themselves as weak they
don't show strength
they don't externalize it they give in
they are the
material that is worked upon you could
say he says
their essence their effects their
reality as if this were a
voluntary achievement as if they chose
to do this
he goes on willed chosen a deed
a meritorious act this sort of person
needs to believe in a neutral
independent
subject right who then
is good by not choosing to behave
in a bad way so the the
use of this neutral subject is a way of
you could say
corralling culturally the strong
using a sort of metaphysics you say the
strong could behave
like the weak and be good instead of
evil they choose not to they choose to
give in to their base desires
for domination and conflict and you know
being a mean
person and all that that's why they're
evil that's why they're they're
uh terrible in that way they could have
chosen otherwise and the weak
for their part are strong in that they
choose
not to behave like the strong even
though they really
in their heart of hearts according to
nietzsche they don't have that that's
not a possibility for them
that's why they're weak right so what we
have here
is some very interesting reflections
on strength and weakness and how they
display themselves
and whether there is any underlying
being and the being in this case would
be the
the will understood as the radically
free will that chooses either good or
evil
but isn't you know by itself driven to
one of these expressions or the other
and nietzsche thinks that that is a
not just a mistaken conception of human
nature
but it's one that serves ideological
needs on the part of the week
to try to get over on the strong through
the
this dynamic of resentment
you